[Music]
[Applause]
greetings everyone i am mark brown the
world champion of public speaking and i
must tell you i am absolutely thrilled
today because today i have the honor the
joy the blessing and the privilege of
introducing you to our newest world
champion of public speaking
all the way from cape town south africa
the first south african world champion
and only the sixth woman to win that
coveted title please help me welcome the
newest member of my world champion
family verity price hello verdi
hello mark wow amazing to be here
well we are just excited to meet you
because this great buzz around the world
now having the first world champion from
the continent of africa and in south
africa what has it been like for you
over the last couple of days since
winning that title
it has been extraordinary it's been
overwhelming it's it's been the most
incredible feeling the love that i felt
coming my way
has been
unbelievable to be honest and the
excitement in africa and southern africa
is palpable i think this means so much
to my district and to the continent that
finally we've brought this title to
africa and now people are going how do
we keep it here
well from me from my fellow world
champions and from the toastmasters
universe hearties congratulations we're
all so proud of you and i know everyone
listening wants to know a little bit
about the journey you took to get to the
world stage or only our second virtual
conference but what was the journey like
where did it all begin for you as a
toastmaster
well my toastmasters journey began 10
years ago so i'm one of the those
stories of someone who's been here a
long time and been getting the most out
of the organization that i could and my
first ever contest was in 2012 and my
sister beat me
at the club i was very unimpressed
and she beat me with her cc6 for people
who remember the legacy program she'd
only done six features and i was already
a professional speaker so i was quite
arrogant thinking i've got this
but she went on to come second to ryan
avery in the semi-finals that year
yeah and her journey k price lindsay put
the name out there because she is my
absolute idol and she let me live in her
spare room for a long time
her journey through the contest really
showed me how much you can grow as a
speaker and as a person by going on the
contest journey i had no idea how much
growth could happen in one speech you
know you think you write a speech once
and it's done
but watching her i saw how much you
could work on a speech so when it came
to entering last year or the beginning
of this year i knew that i had a lot of
work ahead of me if i managed to go
through the levels now when you entered
was your mindset one of i will be the
next world champion of public speaking
or i'm going to have fun
or somewhere in the middle
that is a very good question
i had a strange experience mark i did my
semi-final speech the challenge was
actually my level one icebreaker when i
started pathways last year
and when i wrote it something in me went
this could be a contest speech
and then another voice said this could
get you to the world finals and i don't
know where that voice came from because
i haven't competed in six years
and i it just stayed with me this funny
sense of maybe this could take me all
the way
but the commitment was
however far it takes me i wanted to grow
me as a speaker and as a person
and i was saying to someone the only way
i can explain that voice that i had was
like if you go on a first date and you
look at someone and think oh i could
marry this person you've still got to
date them you've still got to get to
know them but you have that sense so
that's been my journey with the contest
because at each level when they're
announcing the winners i've never had a
sense of like yes i'm going to win this
i always thought there was another
speaker that deserved to also play so i
thought maybe their name was going to be
said so it's been a wonderful delight
throughout
with this other knowing that he's like
maybe this could happen
well the good news is the journey for
you wasn't quite like dating frogs was
it
[Laughter]
so tell me
you know as you you're here you've been
speaking on the main stage you're a
speaker by profession but now you've got
to adjust to the virtual stage and
competing in a virtual stage what kind
of adjustments did you think you had to
make to be effective using this
particular medium
i was quite lucky mark at the start of
lockdown my work had to go online but
between work going online and
toastmasters being so quick to also all
our meetings went online so i was
getting a lot of time on zoom always
seated like this it was only when i
watched the conference last year and uh
particularly my car's winning
performance when i saw what someone
could do with the screen because i
hadn't even thought to do that as a
speaker i was using the check box i was
interacting with people on the screen
but i'd never thought that you could
perform
in this funny confined space so it was
only when i entered the contest that i
said right
how do i use this space how do i have
fun with it and feel like i've got an
audience with me even though i can't see
them how do i feel like i'm connecting
on the other side of that camera so it
really was a play record myself try
things at my club meetings and then i
watched all the champion uh the
finalists from last year and got a lot
of inspiration from each and every one
of them
wonderful now you told us earlier verity
you're on this journey and you you know
doing this dating thing and going
through every level not feeling that
confident this time around your sister
taught you a lesson about that
however at some point you begin to think
this is possible you've won district and
you know you've got a regional
semi-final a semi-final then a final
were you thinking then that this really
could be it for me
it was these two sides there was one
side that was crystal clear that it it
was meant to happen and the other side
doubted it and was like really no don't
be ridiculous so it's it's felt like a
tug of war and last monday so two days
before the semi-finals
i had a moment of i burst into tears
going but what if i did win what if oh
that's too much
that would be that would be so scary to
even imagine that it could happen
and i managed to bring that down and
when i i woke up at three in the morning
to hear that i'd gotten through
to the finals
it was just sitting with that of going
okay
you're here you've got a second speech
that you've given everything to not
knowing if you'd ever get to deliver it
on this stage and now just trust trust
that this is what you want to say
and and do it from your heart because
for me the the result is amazing
but um in our briefing with jim
his name escapes me
the kind of contest
93 no the winner the uh champion
o3 jim key
jim key sorry i could see his name jim
key gave us such a beautiful briefing
for all the finalists and it was just so
much about
here you are you are eight people that
have worked so hard to get here but what
matters is the message that you've
worked on and the people that are going
to hear it and the impact that it's
going to have
and that briefing for me just
centered everything and i thought this
is just about my my speech
my journey my story
whatever the results are i know i just
want to come from my heart and i want to
come from that place so so jim's
briefing for us really was it was such a
beautiful moment for me
well wonderful you said it's about your
speech your story your journey so let me
dive a little bit deeper on that
particular point verdi how did you
arrive
at a great read can you share a little
bit of background on that
i i when i won district i knew there was
going to be a wait before we heard if we
were through and i knew i couldn't wait
to be
working on a second speech so i wrote
two different speeches
uh one was about my dad an amazing
mentorship lesson i'd learned from him
but it just it wasn't finding it then i
wrote another one about overcoming my
own fear of public speaking and that
wasn't finding it
and what ended up being a great read was
a speech that woke me up at three in the
morning and off i went to start typing
and that was a hundred days before the
final
and it reminded i just had this memory
of this of this time in my life that had
been so dark and that my dad's wisdom
had helped me
but it started off as a very different
speech it started off as what i had
actually done which was a
challenge on facebook called hundred
happy days to take pictures of things
that made me happy and i wrote that
whole speech and then i delivered it
thinking this is my speech and all the
men that watched it were like
happy days it's very fluffy
and i was quite upset i thought oh i
thought this was a universal message and
that's when the work started going how
do i tell the same story
but
shift it so that it works for everyone
and it doesn't alienate some people in
the audience
and that the great read only came two
weeks before the finals because
two weeks so same speech but i had a
different message
and
gary tintinger who was our 2017 district
representative at the semi-finals he
evaluated it at a club meeting and he
said i love your speech and this is
working this is working this is working
i'm worried about originality you you're
basing it on a wayne dyer quote and it's
wonderful but i wonder if you might lose
points can't you find your own
you know message line and i was like
what two weeks before don't say that to
me
but it was the best feedback i went and
i looked at what i'd written i phoned my
sister who's always on the on the call
for me if i needed her
and we're like what am i saying what was
dad telling me to do and it was write a
different story and with my sister's
help and lance miller's help he was
coaching me we got to just write a
different story and then
the whole speech for me came together
because the fairy tale analogy came in
the book analogy
and all around the same story and that's
what's interesting for me in the speech
writing process is you can have one
story but the more you work on it
the more you refine it and suddenly you
find the best way to give it to the
audience but i didn't get there on my
own i needed feedback from people for me
to see what was missing
well you just told us two very important
things you said you may have one story
but the more you work on it the more you
refine it it gets better and you realize
you needed help and you hinted to us you
did get some help from world champion 05
lance miller and i have some inside info
on that but how did you
what would you say to us is the value of
getting coaching particularly when
everyone wants to give you an opinion
left right and center how do you sift
through and decide what's best for you
the coaching is key mark and actually
watching your podcast with darren i
learned a lot about the difference
between feedback and coaching and it was
only when i started delivering at clubs
that i realized how valuable that
insight was because you're getting
feedback all the time
when i sat down with a coach and i had
to choose you know who am i going to
entrust this journey to and lance and i
had actually met before when i hosted
him in south africa when i was a
division director so there was a lovely
connection there
and between him and my sister kay who i
really trust she's a fantastic speech
mentor
i had to really have those were the two
voices i was going to listen to
and then when i was getting open
feedback from clubs i had to start
looking for patterns in the feedback
so the first time i heard something i'd
have to sometimes it was instant oh that
person's got a point let me try that but
other times it was like ooh
in my semi-final speech people kept
saying we need to hear more of what
happens at your mom's funeral what did
people say in the book because i just
used to mention there was a book and
then they said can we see the book and
after four different clubs that said the
same thing
then i went and applied the feedback
but my coaching was i'm trusting this
person i know they're on my side and if
they push me and it's uncomfortable it's
because they see something i can't see
it
and so lance i did tell him the first
call i had with him my ego resisted
every bit of feedback he was giving me i
was so attached to my semi-final speech
i was like i've nearly got to district
with this now he's telling me to change
it i watched myself resisting but i took
notes and when i got off the call i gave
myself a talking to and i said he's a
world champion listen to him go change
your speech
and it was a game changer well that's
that's interesting because you're saying
you are you're a world champion now but
you saw the value of getting help from
someone who has been where you wanted to
be
that being said i always say you are the
president of your presentation you make
the decisions
looking back is there anything in your
speech you think you would have changed
not only in terms of content but the way
you delivered because now the video is
out there over 17 000 views in three
days whatever the case may be and the
world is watching and perhaps you
watched yourself a few times have you
said to yourself uh i should have done
that i should have waited here what are
you telling yourself now you know that
you get to see it from the audience's
perspective
well the honest truth is i've watched i
watched it i've watched it once and i
haven't actually watched it again
because i was so glad to not have to
deliver it again i was like oh i've
dreamt and eaten and slept that that
speech
but when i did watch it the thing that i
notice and i'm very critical of myself
but i was very happy with what i did in
fact it was better than i thought it was
such a blur in the contest suddenly you
see the lights come on you finished
i was very happy when i saw it i was
like oh it came across better than i
thought i'd done
but the thing i always see that i always
would do different is more pauses
and
sometimes i that's the i am a speaker
who doesn't pause a lot i have to
remember to
but that's the one thing
to do that more and it's difficult in
the virtual space because you're not
waiting for a laugh and working with the
audience but that was the big thing but
in terms of
that was the speech i wanted to give and
i'm very grateful i think it was dale
carnegie the three speeches the one you
practice the one you give and the one
you wish you gave yeah
when you've worked for 100 days on a
speech and you've implemented so much
feedback and it's suddenly come together
that was the speech i wanted to give and
i feel so grateful because i've never
felt like that my semi-final speech
there were still things i might have
changed
but my final speech was that was the
best that speech was going to be for me
i'm sure it'll grow and change but i'm
i'm
i'm so happy i'm content oh that's
wonderful i must insert two quick
comments here one
one of my
friends a fellow world champion morgan
macarthur who won in 94 told me he beat
me 94 but he told me write a speech you
can't wait to give
and having done that you must really
feel not only have you given the speech
you wanted but you left a message that
you wanted and my other comment is this
i suspect there is a program coming a
hundred days to your victory somewhere
in your future
but that with that thought of you of
wanting to give that speech
what was what was driving what was
burning inside you that said the
audience across the world needs to hear
this
what was burning in you that said i must
i must tell them this
i think we live in a world where we we
have a lot of rules about what our lives
should look like and i certainly was
someone who subscribed to that i left
school
thinking it was all going to happen for
me and it was going to be perfect
because i wanted it i wanted to be you
know i wanted to be a famous singer i
wanted to be married i wanted i had all
these things i wanted to do and my life
didn't turn out that way my dad died
when i was 24 my mom became an alcoholic
i've had a lot of failed relationships
and i suffered from depression because i
couldn't accept that i was so angry with
life that i've worked hard and
why is everyone else getting what i want
and my life changed when i accepted
where i was and you know at 40 and as a
woman i was very subscribed to that kind
of what it's meant to look like not all
people do have that but i think i don't
think i'm alone in wanting that
and i had to let it go
and in that letting go that was when my
life changed and you know yes suddenly
it sounds like i had the fairy tale but
if i can give hope that it's never too
late it's never too late to step into
something else to change your story
to turn things around
it might not end up exactly the way you
expect
but when you have made peace with that
and you realize that you are actually in
control of your experience of your life
not necessarily your circumstances but
your experience that's when life changes
and
with where the world is at right now
that's the only place a lot of us can
find freedom because we don't have
control over our circumstances so that's
why i wanted to share it because many of
us are locked in spare rooms not by our
own choosing but if it gives someone
hope to to shift that then i'm i'm so
happy
many of us are locked in spare rooms not
of our own choosing
that is lyrical and almost poetic and i
noticed in your presentation you had
some lines that were really catchy i'm
sure would resonate the line about a
scary tale
how did that come about it's a wonderful
line everyone have talked to us loves it
did that did you happen upon it how did
you arrive at that particular line
so i actually thought it was maybe too
cheesy i nearly left it out it came in
two days before the finals i suddenly
realized it
so that line came from a few bits of
feedback the the one was earlier
versions of the speech where my message
was i was saying look for the good
people felt was a bit soft and going but
your life wasn't that hard and you're
making light of depression so i realized
i needed to mention that my ego had a
problem with what my life looked like
not that my life was that hard
so i was trying to work that out and
then actually it was feedback i got at
renaissance speakers lance miller's club
one of his club members said
at the beginning when you've set up what
your life looks like you need to find a
line similar to what lance had
around i had a couple of room name mates
named mom and dad it just paints the
picture
and suddenly i was like i've been
talking about fairy tales and for my ego
this was the scary tale and it just
it was playful so i'm so glad i stuck it
in because i nearly left it out but my
sister heard it she was like i love that
go for it
and
i've had a few messages about the scary
tale well see if you say again you
almost left it in but your sister said
you almost took it out and your sister
said no leave it in so
talk to us talk to toastmasters who are
around the world who may be new
who are struggling with the idea of what
do i take out what do i leave in is
there a process you can share with us to
decide is are there iterations what's
your process there of sifting through
it's it's an interesting one i mean
obviously in a normal toastmasters
context you give a speech once and you
might deliver it again with a few
changes but it's only in the context
that you really start shaping a speech
which is similar to if you're a
professional speaker and you're working
on a keynote
i was quite attached to some things i
had a line in my speech around the humor
of people always asking if they're on
mute
and zoom meetings
and then i kept getting feedback on my
google forms like that's so dan all the
comedians are doing it leave it out and
i was keeping it in because i thought it
was funny and lance said you can't keep
something in just because you think it's
funny you know sometimes listen to your
audience and and trust that so
it's
it's a lot of refining but that's why i
don't think you can do it on your own
you have to have some safe people that
you can bounce things off
and learn how to
learn how to refine and then also what
to put in
maybe just to to give some context
the story stayed the same for a long
time it was how i left the spare room
and i'd met my husband and i had a baby
but it was also probably four weeks
before the finals at one club someone
said i don't hear the timeline you're
not telling me how long that took you're
telling me to write a different story
but now how quickly will my life change
so then i was like oh you need to know
that happened after six months that
happened after a year this took four
years
and and that was really useful because i
hadn't thought to put it in because i'm
not you sometimes forget to put yourself
in the audience shoes and go they don't
know the story and what are the gaps for
them that need to be in there so you
have to ask someone what's missing what
didn't make sense to you what can i add
in here
well you just also gave us some wisdom
you said listen to your audience because
i've learned your audience can't help
you write your presentation
so i want to dig a little bit deeper on
your process in terms of timeline as
well you say 100 days to create this
masterpiece
was there a point in time when you said
i'm not going to lock in my script this
is it no more changes and after that
what was your practice routine or
rehearsal routine
so that was probably about two days
before the finals i suddenly said that's
enough although on the day of the finals
my sister added something in for me
which was kissing my prince that was new
i said i met my husband but suddenly
were like you've been kissing frogs you
can kiss a prince and it just was fun
and it was easy to add in so that's that
we put in
but i didn't actually practice that much
towards the end because i was so
overwrought and i couldn't see the
speech anymore and i actually had to
just
let it go and trust that all that work
all that practice would pay off
when i did the contest
otherwise i would have been rehearsing
right up to the end and and that also
came from watching probably one of these
interviews that was had with mike carr
after his
win last year he also said he eventually
had to stop practicing because
you start doubting yourself so i
eventually did let it go
and it was pretty locked in but there
was a there was a fluidity when we said
oh let's add in a fun thing it was easy
to add it in because i was comfortable
one more question for you regarding that
process
now when i was competing a gazillion
years ago in a previous millennium
it was a little bit different we had a
couple of months between our semi-final
it was called regional back then and the
final in august
in your case
it's a matter of days
what is it like to prepare two speeches
within a short window and how do you
decide which goes first and which goes
second
if you have two ready tell us a bit
about that very please
i think i was very committed to my my
district speech was the one i would do
for the semi-finals i didn't ever think
i could swap them around so maybe if i
had that as an option i would have had
it would have been a harder choice
but doing two speeches concurrently was
incredibly challenging i would log on to
clubs and do one speech to get a whole
lot of feedback and then gather myself
and do the next speech so it was it was
a brain
twister i'll put it that way
but again i mean when as a speaker do
you get to stretch yourself like that i
would never put myself under that
pressure and you know learning how
two different speeches two very
different styles of
delivery in certain ways
but it was it was full-on and i was so
grateful once the semi-final was
recorded i mean i just let that speech
go it was like and i'm done and my brain
was like oh just focus on one so i
recommend that just focusing on one
but it does i'm sure all the
semi-finalists would agree with me that
the process would have grown them as
speakers and as presenters
well in terms of the growth just being
in the contest how would you define or
describe your growth over the last six
or eight months
sure
it's
it's shown me that i can put everything
into something and go for it and commit
and just
trust myself that i've decided to pick a
path and go for it
and it's i think through the coaching
process and it's i spoke briefly about
it earlier with lance
was it made me confront my ego
and realizing how quickly i can get
attached to thinking what i'm doing is
is working
and then having to go have a growth
mindset listen take that feedback
don't assume you've got this sorted you
know if someone's saying something
consider it see if you can shift so it's
really taught me to be a lot more open
to feedback a lot more flexible in just
quickly changing and pivoting and not
being but that's the way i'm doing it
and i've mentored a lot of speakers so i
know what it's like someone goes but
that's my story and that's what happened
and you're saying don't ruin a good
story with the facts and they don't want
to listen
i was that person so the the growth has
come from
getting feedback at an 8 00 am meeting
and adapting it and applying it at a 12
pm meeting and just
practicing and going and changing
because i think if i can take that into
my business and into the rest of my life
it's going to be a life skill
ah now for the two tough questions i
ring my hands
the evil two questions
what is the one thing
first part you learned about
audiences
and virtual audiences through this
process and part two is what is the most
important thing you learned about verity
price
going through this process
wow
so virtual audiences is an interesting
one because in the contest space you are
literally performing to your own picture
it's really strange it's like in the
bathroom treading to yourself in the
mirror
so that was quite confronting initially
but in fact when i went to clubs where
people didn't switch their cameras off
that was even stranger because then you
saw someone having a cup of tea and
someone's shouting at someone and you
it's very hard to to remain focused
so in a contest virtual audience space
it's it's an unusual one very different
to if i'm running an event where i'm the
online mc and i can i can be interacting
with people i didn't have that
opportunity
so the the virtual audience is you've
got to trust yourself you've got to
trust that what you've worked on is
landing and that the humor is landing
even if you can't get that feedback and
that's when you've got to pause as if
they're laughing even though you don't
know that they are
it's really strange
but um it's yeah it's been it's been a
good journey but i do look forward to
the more interactive zoom meetings where
i can see faces and we can use the chat
box
but what have i learned about verity
price
i've learned that i don't give up on my
dreams
and even though i've put them on the
shelf for a long a long time it's
i i had a dream at 20 that i had
something to say to the world i started
working as a i started writing songs and
and i thought i would share my message
with the world through songs
and then that didn't quite work out and
then i was speaking but at a small level
and suddenly at 46 years old i've been
given this opportunity to share my words
my message with the world and it's it's
a privilege and it's a it's humbling and
i'm just so grateful i'm so grateful
that i i showed up and i committed and
my husband said yes to putting our
two-year-old to bed so that i could
practice over and over again
um and yeah i just discovered i was way
more tenacious than i realized
ah you discovered your tenacity well i
speak personally but i believe there are
at least 85 000 people who might agree
with me on this you also speak a message
you spoke a message of hope to all of us
it is never too late to pursue a dream i
do have to ask a personal question also
in all this process how did the prince
handle his role
as your supporter as your spouse as the
father of your child as your life
partner what was that like for him as
well
he he would tell you that he became a
frog at some points because it was
really tiring
but he was
unbelievable and he never doubted for a
second he kept saying to me you're doing
this because you're gonna win and i was
like no come on let's and he just said
i've got such a sense that this is why
you're putting in this time and
he picked up the slack but it's not easy
we've got a beautiful 15 months old when
i started this journey that's a lot of
bedtime routines you know dad running
around after a baby but he did it and
getting up at seven in the morning
getting kicked out our bedroom so i
could practice speeches it was
extraordinary
well having that support is so important
i realized that and now you have made it
to the world stage you have won this
contest and i'm you know when i won mine
26 years ago i didn't fully comprehend
what that meant
now the images of the video have gone
globally and you are now a presence in
the toastmasters world
what's next for the 2021 world champion
of public speaking
it's quite something hearing that title
my word
take it in
for me mark it it's really to keep
building on the work i already do i am
already a speaker and i speak on mindset
and on thinking differently and how to
overcome your obstacles
and what this speech has done is it's
given me a a new way to hold that
message so i want to turn
a great read into a keynote into a
workshop that i can offer to people so
that they can use the
tools that i've learned over the last 10
years and my work specifically positive
psychology tools and habits that make
the difference with writing a different
story so
i'm letting it percolate i feel like
there could be a book in there somewhere
but i just i'm excited to to take what
was a seven minute speech and turn it
into a broader offering
that can help people to actually do what
i did and that's the hundred days the
gratitude the reframing problems there's
these very specific steps that i did
that obviously i couldn't cover in a
seven minute speech so that's my that's
my next step is how to add more value
with that message oh i am so excited to
hear that because
so many people believe
i win the world title i've got a great
speech whoa i will now conquer the world
but i so admire your intent and you say
you want to create no you will create
the keynote you will create the workshop
you will write the book you may even do
a podcast i am predicting for you here
verity but i deeply appreciate that you
take this message that you have and now
see it as a as a tool you can then share
with the world out there and i'll be
honest with you i can't wait to hear
what you have to show the world
there is one last part of your life i
want to touch on briefly
i'm be made aware you do sing like a
bird and you have done some vocal work
you've recorded some music do you ever
sing in your presentations
i do i do i finish my my two keynotes
finish with songs so it's always lovely
i i get to have my pop star moment at
the end of the keynote
and whenever i run workshops for
companies or you know a strategy session
or a thinking workshop i never get away
without them asking me to sing so i've
learned to sing in the strangest
situations and funny little pokey rooms
but
again it's an opportunity to share my
message in a different way and i'm
always grateful for that
well in the last two minutes that we
have we got two minutes to go in our
conversation today very
did you consider
thinking did you consider or think about
singing as part of your world champion
speech
i didn't
i thought i didn't think it i felt like
it would be strange to do so no i didn't
i've loved it for some i know it's been
done before and was wonderful but it
wasn't relevant i maybe if they've been
a different speech it might have worked
but not for this one
well i want to thank you for saying that
because my last comment is this you have
given us nuggets today about how you
think about relevance what you leave in
what you take out and you've taken us
part way through the process you went
through as you developed this
presentation going forward you said you
want to do a keynote workshop book and
maybe more as part of your message
i don't think you realize verity
what the world is going to require of
you expect requests from districts and
clubs all over the world they'll want to
hear your message of resilience of hope
of being able to hold on to your dream
and see your dream becoming realized
right now
you've told us what your next steps are
going to be i would encourage you to
enjoy what you have accomplished to
continue to share your messages and i do
have one more question for you for the
new toastmasters who will look in awe
and say oh my goodness a woman from
south africa has won the world
championship is it possible that i can
be a world champion too
what do you say to answer the question i
have been asked by women all over the
world for 20 years
how can women be more prominent and what
can we do to win the world championship
and by answering this you will let me
and my brothers off the hook
i love it
i think as women we have to own our
stories we have to be comfortable
talking about uncomfortable things and
find a message that speaks to everyone i
think that i spoke about wanting a fairy
tale it's a very female thing but
i've found a way that it applied for men
as well i've had so many men reach out
and say what that message meant for them
and that makes me so happy
so we need to own our stories but find
the universal appeal and message in it
and i think for women we have we carry a
lot and if this had not been a virtual
conference i couldn't have done this
i've got a little boy it would have been
really difficult to travel
so we need partners that support us and
and without my husband greg picking up
that slack i wouldn't have had the
capacity to do this and i honestly think
that's a main reason why women haven't
always featured is that they haven't had
the time available to them to commit
those six months to just their goals and
i stand corrected on that but it's it's
a sense that i that i have and as women
we sometimes have to own that we want to
do something and we want to have an
impact and then we need to set up the
support structure around us so that we
can get out there and share
our voice our word our message in our
way and there's so much space for women
to be on the stage and i'm just so
privileged to be one of many to come
final question what are your closing
words of encouragement to anyone who is
considering entering the international
speech contest
enter
you have to be in it to win it
enter but look at those who've come
before you watch i mean i watched or
mark i've watched your speeches i've
watched all the the world championships
learn
from what the champions have done and
then find your story find what it is you
want to talk about and do it for you
because the outcome is not guaranteed
but the journey is an exceptional one
however far it takes you and just commit
to seeing where it takes you and how it
grows you as a person and as a speaker
verity price the 2021 world champion of
public speaking thank you for your time
today you are the beginning of your new
journey and we just can't wait to see
where it leads you friends once again i
am mark brown the 1995 world champion of
public speaking it's been my joy my
pleasure and my privilege to introduce
you to our newest world champion verity
price keep speaking and keep changing
your world
thank you so much
thank you
you